- You should really go to a
retirement home one day and
volunteer and just talk to them.
It will make you want to do
shit every minute of your life
because when you see
regret in a man's eyes
it's fucking painful
because you can't
do shit about it.
When you're 90 and you're not
mobile and you're tired and
it's over you can't do
any, you can't do it.
You can't build that company
you wanted, you can't spend that
time with your kid.
It's regret.
And it fucking drives
the shit out of me.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Woman] Good.
How are you?
- Good. What's cooking?
How is the year going?
- [Woman] Good.
- [Gary] What does radio do?
What did TV do?
I think what, when the
pavements going to hit here is
how are you measuring all the
other activities, right?
So everybody loves
to say you're right.
And that's why I went there.
Mazel Tov that you want us to
prove our $50,000 on Facebook
sold shit but I want to
understand how your 400,000 on
print, catalog and what other
horseshit that you're doing is
selling because you have
the challenge that to
have a fair conversation.
- Gary it's so hard it to
be in a meeting with you.
- I know, I railroad 'em.
- It's so hard.
- It is.
- Just never feel pretty
enough next to you, Gary.
It's so hard.
- Which is so inappropriate
'cause you're so pretty.
(laughter)
- I love it.
It's been a while
since I've seen--
- The action. Right?
- It's been like
a year and half.
- It's maximizing that.
- But you still shut
down most weekends--
- Yes, family, I have to.
I work so much that if I don't
do that, I won't have a family.
- Exactly, yeah.
That must be a tough one then.
- It is tough, it is tough.
And it ebbs and flows.
They're getting older now
and I'm taking more time.
- How old are the kids?
- Seven and four.
- Okay.
- They're starting to
become real people, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're an inspiration.
- Thank you, brother.
- Inspiration.
- Thank you.
What's your name?
- John.
- John. Good for you.
- Can I take a photo?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- [Man] You're like the
champion of the world now.
- Quite a bit.
- [Man] Yeah, okay.
Love your stuff.
- Thanks for saying hello.
- Best of luck.
- [Gary] Talk to you.
Stay well.
- [Eric] I really like that.
- [Gary] Me too.
I thought the
vibes were very good.
Yeah it is.
Who's going, all of us?
(light music)
- Gary!
- [Gary] What's up?
- I'm a fan.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Jonas] Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you.
- [Jonas] Could I
take a quick selfie?
- [Gary] Sure, sure.
- Sorry to interrupt you.
- [Gary] That's okay, it's okay.
- [Jonas] Enjoy London.
- What's your name?
- Jonas.
- Jonas, nice to meet you, man.
Thanks for saying hello.
- What are you doing here?
- [Gary] We have an office here.
- Oh cool.
- [Gary] So just doing business.
Well that's most places.
- Right.
- Oh my God, we look great.
- We look terrible.
- No, we look amazing.
- You look terrible,
I look phenomenal.
Well, I guess you
look phenomenal.
- No.
- And I look terrible as a girl.
That's so amazing.
- Wow, I got to save that photo.
- Happens.
Yep, awesome.
Cool.
Talk to you, see you.
(laughter from group)
I still, I can't see it.
- [Woman 2] You
can read the sign?
- Oh the Wine Library?
I love it.
You know how many times
this is been shot to me.
- Are you serious?
- Uh-huh.
I've had so many people
take this picture for me.
That's awesome.
- Hello. How are you?
- [Peter] Pretty good.
- Good, I'm Gary.
- Oh hi, yeah, I thought.
- How are you?
- Good. Peter.
- Peter, such a pleasure.
How are you?
- So who came first, you or me?
(laughter from group)
- I think you, if it's '88.
I changed the name in
'96 so definitely you.
- Oh right.
- So real pleasure.
Real pleasure.
How are you?
- Yes, good.
- Good.
So many people send me that
picture of your sign out there.
- Oh really?
- Through the years, yeah.
Awesome, yeah.
I gotta do some shopping.
(light music)
Yeah, real pleasure.
I'll see you soon again.
(light music)
Good, just doing some
new business meetings.
Somebody's got to
make money around here.
All good stuff?
(light music)
You know, I'll tell you
why wine was such a
home run for me.
I'm a story, I love storytelling
and wine is the perfect,
do you know how crazy wine is?
There's unlimited products
and they change every year.
Not only are there like
1,000,001 stories but the story
between this wine in 2013
and this wine in 2014 has
a whole 'nother story.
You get to talk about like the
rain and the sun or how they
farmed it that year.
It's unlimited and plus the
other thing that's fun about
storytelling is--
- [Man 2] Thank you.
- is you love to tell stories in
categories where people are
intimidated so people are
really intimidated by wine.
- [Man 3] Somebody asked me
how I pick it and I said--
- By the label.
Intuitively.
A sign that says
something about it.
Bought some wine for
the London office.
Ryan, Megs good?
Good?
- [Megs] Awesome.
You did so good.
- You did that so
well, you snuck in.
- [Eric] I do think there
could be a ridiculous
amount of business there.
(light chatter)
(light music)
- 'Sup, brother?
- How are you, mate?
- Good to see you.
- Doing well?
- I'm doing well.
- Good.
- Let's do it.
- I'd love to get you
to, let me show you this.
Ironically since we did
VaynerWorld I haven't been able
to follow the content as
closely because--
- You've been busy.
- so busy, yeah.
It's almost like the graduation
of following you is
to stop following you.
- You know--
- Do you get it?
- Do I get it?
You know I put out content like
that, it's all I talk about.
Of course,
watching that makes me smile.
I know what that is.
- Yeah.
- And so of course.
(crash)
- [Raj] Sorry, mate.
- [Rafal] No,
it's not your fault.
It's a 5D.
- [Raj] It should
be strong enough.
- [Gary] It's okay?
- [Rafal] It's fine,
it still records.
I want that to be at the end.
- [Gary] Oh, that's
going to make it.
That's going to make it.
(laughter)
I'm putting this
right in my car.
I got to go to this meeting.
- Alright. Always good
to see you, man.
- See you man.
- Take care.
- Love you man.
- Thanks man.
- Talk to you soon.
Talk to you soon, brother.
Hotel I slept for two
hours and that's it.
So I'm on three hours of sleep.
- [Man 3] Well I've been
Tomorrowland all week.
- And then I'm leaving,
then I'm, oh, is that right?
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- [Gary] Awesome.
Yeah. It's really cool.
Well, great.
Thanks for getting together.
It was a lot of
fun jamming in LA.
- Yeah.
I got something to back it up.
(light music)
- When you really look at the
business how many buckets can
the business play in that is of
sizable meaningness for you to
spend money to
create and deploy?
- Alright, let's do it.
Whole Batman
thing, to the roof.
(light music)
This is nice.
- I went out see
our official office.
That's where we're moving into.
(light music)
- I think that's very
subjective to the end user.
I think that, I think that way
too many people want to be the
judge and the jury of high
quality content but at the end
of the day high quality content
is completely answered by the
audience that it's
trying to reach.
So for example as you can
imagine with me I'm in an
aggressive Jersey guy.
Sometimes I curse in my content.
A lot of people in a certain
demo and definitely in a certain
mindset think it's very high
quality if not the most high
quality business content
on the internet.
Then there's a lot of other
people that are conservative and
are quote-unquote more
professional, buttoned up that
see me wearing a T-shirt and
cursing and think it's the
lowest quality, right?
That it's crass.
I think that it's super
important to recognize that high
quality content is judged by
the market that the content is
trying to reach.
Yeah, I think that's an
interesting place to take it.
I do think that content that is
from a personal, look, I think
any personal brand, any
individual that is in acting
mode is creating vulnerability.
I think the more that you are
who you are the more upside you
have with what you're doing.
- [Man 4] Hey Gary.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- [Man 4] It's good to see you.
- [Gary] How have you been?
- I'm good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good.
I've been really well.
- Yeah?
- I'm glad you made it tonight.
- Well, thank you.
Thank you for inviting me.
- I'm starting to realize,
like everybody saying, I didn't
realize 10 o'clock was an
unusual thing in London so
I'm pumped with the turnout.
I'm so proud of the turnout.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It should be fun.
I'll get us started in a minute.
- Okay, great.
- Thank you so much
for coming together.
Eric and I were talking about my
next trip to London I said,
"You know what? I want to do
something that I've
"been doing for a long time with
a bunch of new friends,
"people that I maybe
met once or twice,"
and this turnout was super fun.
I think you guys are
going to really enjoy this.
What I'm about to tell you about
is probably the singular reason
I still go to conferences.
So I'm going to start
this by telling you a story.
In SXSW 2008
that was the year when it
was starting to get bigger.
Twitter popped the year before
and there was like three times
more people that came to
South-By then the year before
and of course anybody that's
come before you know how you
hate when anything "sells out."
It's like a band or
anything of that nature.
All of us people were
like, "Oh, it's selling out.
"It's so crowded."
There was lines to
actually get in to a party.
So what happened was
that night me and
my friend, Travis, who went
on to become the cofounder and
CEO of Uber and my friend
Kevin Rose who is probably the
face of the whole web 2.0
movement at the
time as the CEO of Digg.
And so that night,
hey Lars, how are you?
So that night, sit.
Yeah pull up a
different chair, Rhys.
That night we all went into a
hotel room with Dave McClure who
went on to start 500 Startups,
the big venture fund and five or
six other people.
One of the cofounders of
Living Social and we called it
the jam session.
Really cool stuff, so
many fun inside jokes.
One of the big things that we
try to do and one of things that
will be fun tonight is you all
get to know each other, maybe
you'll do it more often, I think
I'm planning on doing a bunch
here in London.
I want to make it kinda a thing,
it's fun to see who
is right and wrong.
(light hip hop music)
I genuinely believe
that IP is the
most underpriced asset and
Marvel really, really struck me.
Pokémon Go I give a
lot of credit to the IP.
(light hip hop music)
I think even this entire table,
this room grossly underestimates
the speed in which technology is
actually going to happen.
Like when you really just take a
step back and think about where
the world was just 10 years
ago so many things that we talk
about as a day-to-day base
infrastructure, cost of entry to
what we live in
today didn't exist.
When you project out 10 more
years of technology,
it's just so extraordinary.
I don't think we sit here three
months ago and think there's
that many tens of millions of
users using an AR app in 90 days
and you just wake up one morning
and over a weekend it's real.
I just think there's a
lot of that going on.
That I think is going to be
really fascinating to see.
I'm a complete believer that
the world is built on the
shadows of our society.
That they're an equal important
infrastructure meaning what's
going on in the US right now
because of live streaming
and where the internet is and
media is we as a country have to
start facing some
of our real issues that
we don't want to face.
I just feel like everything
you do is on the record.
I think privacy is
fundamentally dead
and I just live
within that context.
(light hip hop music)
- [Man 5] So in the past month,
where as like old people told
you about entrepreneurship and
moving forward and hustling?
- You should really go to a
retirement home one day and
volunteer and just talk to them.
It will make you want to do
shit every minute of your life
because when you see
regret in a man's eyes
it's fucking painful.
Because you can't
do shit about it.
When you're 90 and you're not
mobile and you're tired and
it's over you can't do any,
you can't do it.
You can't build that company
you wanted, you can't spend that
time with your kid.
It's regret.
And it fucking drives
the shit out of me.
It just drives the
living shit out of me.
You know what I mean, mate?
- My thing and get to begin
to build that foundation.
- How old are you?
- I'm 27.
- You got fucking time.
It's a balance of
regret and patience.
You can go hard on for three
years, do nothing right, wake-up
and be young as fuck.
I'd rip my arm off to be 35.
Five years, take it.
You know?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That would be the
biggest thing I would tell you.
- Just go all in.
- Yeah.
And recognize where
you are in the system.
Right, obviously, everybody
can have a tragic thing but
you're a young man.
And you got a lot of time.
So it's like pulling equally
from ambition and no regret but
equally being patient.
They're contradictions and
finding the balance of the two
is where all the magic is.
- Dude, I hate you man.
- 12:24 I'm heading out.
I don't need you
following me to the hotel.
I'm going to sleep, see ya.
(light hip hop music)